- [interviewer] All right Norman.
Welcome back.
- Hey.
- [interviewer] So how are things going?
It's been since we met
it's been about a month
and a half a month.
- Yeah about a month.
- [interviewer] Yeah a
little over a month I think.
what's going on as of today?
- Well as of today
I have one day
we had a relapse that happened.
You know, what I suffer
from is unpredictable
you don't know when that
buck is gonna hit you.
You don't know what the fuck is going on.
This was one that just the
thought came in my head
and I went straight to it.
You know there was no middle
defense no nothing and,
- [interviewer] Was
there something stressful
that kind of caused it or brought on?
- I don't see anything that was stressful
as I tried to look back at
this (indistinct) you know
unconsciously I wanted to get high
and so it moved to the conscious state
and it just is dominating you know,
it's absolutely dominating.
So it's dominated me
and I didn't have to fight.
- [interviewer] You understand
that's part of the process
right?
No one goes.
- I think I'm gaining a better
understanding of how to fast
coz you know, I can kick
my ass better than anybody.
You know and even right now
I still feel down about
I feel like I've let a lot of people down
and things like that.
But the bottom line is
goddammit I'm an addict.
And through the process of recovery
this is gonna happen.
- [Interviewer] It's gonna happen.
So roll with the fucking punches Norman
don't beat yourself up,
just continue to go.
- [Interviewer] That's important.
- And you know,
that's hard for me because
I'm a prideful person.
See so therefore you know
pride got shit to do with it.
So I'm gonna have to drop that shit.
You know I'm gonna ask
God on a daily basis
just get rid of this
because what it's gonna do
is it's gonna lead me down that caution
and I'm be fucked.
You know and I don't wanna be fucked.
- [Interviewer] No you
shouldn't judge yourself
and say I screwed up.
You should just be like
this is part of what happened
it's a setback no big deal.
- And I was gonna actually
ask the job for an extra week.
I'm not asking for shit.
I'm going to a job Thursday.
- [interviewer] Good feel so you start.
- I start Thursday.
- [interviewer] Thursday yeah excellent.
- You know went through my
training and stuff like that.
So I'm going Thursday night,
- [interviewer] Do you think any of this
relapse is caused by your
you've had some success lately?
- Right.
- [interviewer] And sometimes
people have a hard time
accepting good things
in their life success.
And do you think there's any
of that, like, all of a sudden,
you got your life straight,
and you're getting it back
together with your kids
and you have a job and everything
is kind of going in the right direction.
And you need to throw
a wrench in the works.
- I think it was impending doom,
- [interviewer] impending doom of what?
- An impending doom of
the fear of the unknown,
not knowing what's going on.
What I think is gonna go on.
And and you're right.
I mean, here's all of
this monumental success
and so much of a small time that
i don't think i got cocky.
It was supposed to happen.
- [interviewer] Yeah, I think
it's part of the process.
- I'm not even gonna
try to try to answer it
in any way, shape, or form.
That were supposed to
happen knock me down a pig.
Hey, just take it easy.
Don't try to do everything fast.
- [interviewer] Exactly.
- Just, you know, we'll help you.
- [interviewer] Yeah and don't
judge yourself too harshly.
- Yeah, I just, I mean, I
kick my ass man I feel so bad.
- [interviewer] No,
- But I'm getting out of it
you know, slowly but surely.
My good friend, man.
- [interviewer] Donald?
- Yeah, I called him.
And he said, Where are you?
I said I'm not too far away.
We shall be here when you get here.
You know, that's a true friend.
He didn't judge me anything.
He gave me a big old hug.
He said your hungry?
So I had to get something to eat.
It the one last time you got high as well.
It was way like six, seven in the morning
something like that.
So Are you sleepy?
I said, I'm dead tired.
You know, but yeah, we still stayed up
and we talked a little
bit and next thing I know,
it was morning time
- [interviewer] You're lucky to have Dan.
- Yeah, he's very, very good friend, man.
And God bless him man.
- [interviewer] Absolutely.
- You know, it's just,
it's supposed to happen.
They stayed in the rooms that
relapse is a part of recovery.
So now I'm getting an
understanding of that.
Sometimes you have to, excuse me
take a step back in order to move forward.
And if that is the case, then
that's the case. You know,
I said before that I
really don't worry about
what people say think and feel.
But there is a part of me that does.
- [interviewer] Yeah, that's human nature.
You know, because I mean,
you do these this story
like my video and about myself
and so many people commented
that was extremely positive and, you know,
they were uplifting and
I read them every day,
yet it was not substantial
enough to stop me.
So that means more work needs to be done.
You know, maybe we've just
scratched the surface.
we digging underneath, More.
You know, I asked God
just wanting to know,
look, uncover what the hell is wrong.
So I can discover what the fuck is wrong
and I can recover from this shit.
Because this shit is
gonna kill me eventually.
Some people may make become, you know,
judgmental during my journey.
and I gonna make sure that
I take that. You know,
there were a couple of things said,
when I went into this mission for to live
as far as job placement
and stuff like that.
And there were a few
things said that I believe
I don't believe they triggered me.
But I didn't like what they were saying,
he was you know, he's always done this.
So I'm being judged and
looked at in my former sense,
but also have to understand
that this is my present state.
So just because they say
what they say, you know,
it does affect me.
- [interviewer] Yeah but it's not,
it's important to not
listen to anyone else.
- Yeah I gonna stray away from that,
because, you know, I have the type of mind
and has the ability to fuck
me without my permission.
So, you know, God damn.
You, I let the smallest things
become the biggest things.
You know,
- [interviewer] I mean,
I'm not religious at all
and the least religious
person you'll ever meet,
but what helps you in these situations is
how would God judge you?
- I don't think he would,
- [interviewer] He wouldn't.
And that's the key.
- You know,
- [interviewer] I mean, I think, you know,
I've done a lot of these
talks, 2000 or more,
and a lot of them, a lot of
them have been with addicts.
And what I've learned is
addiction is not the real problem.
It's a symptom of a deeper problem.
And that deeper problem is a combination
of the unconditional love
you didn't receive as a child
and whatever that takes a million forms,
the traumatic events that
you're trying to escape
from later on in life, the
environment you grew up in,
and the brain chemistry that you have,
and those all combined
to create a scenario
where you can be self destructive.
And you can sabotage your progress.
And what's the problem with with self love
is it's such a nice little term,
- Right,
- [interviewer] You know,
I'm gonna go get a caramel
macchiato and love myself today.
That's what it's, you
know, it sounds so easy.
But the truth of it is, it's more like
I'm gonna climb Mount Everest barefoot,
with a 75 pound backpack on my shoulders
to prepare myself for the
challenge of loving myself.
That's what it's gonna take,
it's gonna take a tremendous
amount of strength and
courage to love ourselves.
It's the biggest challenge
any of us ever have.
And if you don't take it that seriously,
then you're gonna end up just becoming
you're just gonna find any
distraction to kind of numb
the pain of not being happy.
- And everything is gonna
just hurt, hurt, hurt,
and I'm gonna say Poor me, poor me.
And I don't want to go
into that state you know,
it's slowly but surely
getting off my shoulders
of what I've done.
You know, I have to have
a degree of acceptability
of what I've done.
Okay Norman you did it,
accept it move forward.
You don't have to stay in this rut.
Because when I stay in a rut I keep going
and going and going like
the Energizer Bunny,
I keep going, you know,
yes, I was able to stop.
Not because I ran out of money,
Well, I did run out of money,
but also that was around it.
It was right there it was accessible.
All I had to do was ask, but
I just didn't want anymore.
You know, I think what happens is you get
a moment of clarity and that clarity
hit me about four o'clock in the morning.
What are you gonna do?
Now you've left there.
Now, what are you gonna do?
You got this job.
And I was like, Okay, I
know what I have to do.
I know what I need to do.
But isn't really what I wanna do.
You know, do I wanna stay
out here and just continue?
Or do I want to go ahead and say okay, no,
you made a mistake back up,
take a breath and go.
You know, I'm still going at my job.
Still going to work you know
that fucking one day to day
we got them and I'm going
I'll be there on time, way before time.
And I'm gonna do my job.
And I'm gonna take it easy and stop trying
see I want to carry everything.
I'll say I'll give it to God and I do
but then I'll take some shit back.
Okay, God, thanks a lot I'll take this.
thanks a lot on this one I'll take this.
And I believe and I know
what it's not I believe
this is what happened
I know what happened.
Yeah, I started, It started all blossoming
but I put too much water on it.
- [interviewer] Too much too soon.
- Too much too soon
Instead of just backing up
because see, it's not so much
that I say now I've got it.
You know, this is it I'm great,
- [interviewer] you're fixed,
- but it's like, Okay.
I had an overwhelming desire to succeed.
But, you know, it's
really not about success?
Am I trying to succeed for me?
What am I trying to
succeed for the viewers?
Am I trying to succeed for my family?
I can be an impressionable person,
but goddamn man, I'm an addict.
And I'm struggling.
- [interviewer] It's about
forgiveness and acceptance.
- I'm an addict, and I'm struggling.
And if this is a part of my
recovery with it so be it.
If this is what I have to do.
You know, I'm gonna have
ups I'm gonna have downs.
Yeah, so I gotta, I gotta
start small. You know,
Thank God, I gotta give
kudos to my friend,
thank God for you.
You know, because you know,
you don't, I don't trust man.
I got trust issues and for that man,
looking at me with tears
in his eyes last night,
he gave me a big old hug.
He said, Man, I love you like my brother.
Anytime you need me,
I'll be there for you.
That within itself, really, really
Show me that I can't trust man.
Because every man is not like the man
that did what he did to me you know,
I really never said that one either.
But that I didn't trust me and you know,
because of what has happened to me.
And, you know, here's a guy
who really honestly cares about me.
I'm no relation to him
but he cares about me unconditionally.
There might have been
a lot of others in life
, but I didn't based on
what has happened to me.
So I was judgmental you know,
no matter how good you got
your some motive, you know,
this man has no motive on nothing.
He gave me some necessary
stuff to lay down
and I wouldn't lay down I went to sleep.
You know, thank God for you.
I didn't wanna call you.
I didn't want I didn't want you.
- [interviewer] You lost
your phone doing that.
- Yeah, you know, yeah, this
is never I lost a wallet,
which I have to get all that stuff back.
I lost my phone got to get down back.
Went to the mission this morning
to get my stuff it's gone.
So I'm back to square one.
So if I'm in training,
orientation for new life,
I'm starting back at square one.
- [interviewer] I'm sorry.
- I'm starting back in
square one you know,
- [interviewer] I think
it'd be more setback.
- You know, yeah maybe
I have to be stripped
though I've never lost my wallet.
- [interviewer] Don't be
sorry on yourself though.
- Yeah, but you know, you got to do it.
You got to do it and we can do it.
You know, it can be done I do
have the wherewithal inside
to do it.
- [interviewer] And you
have good days and bad days?
- Yeah, I just have to,
Mark I have to garner
a sense of acceptability
that's what it is.
See, I don't accept failure at all.
I've failed, okay, fuck it.
But something now is different.
Because I had that moment of clarity.
I listened to that little voice.
It took me a while to
access somebody's phone
because I was extremely
tired and I call my buddy.
And he was right there for me.
- [interviewer] I'm not an addict.
So forgive me if I'm off this.
But it seems like it might be
I can relate it to aspects of
you know, things in my life.
I don't do drugs, but it's
like, there's other things
that are basically the same thing.
You made a couple steps forward
and you made a step back.
But where you are perhaps today
is a little tiny bit better
than where you were a
month and a half ago.
- Right, Yes,
- [interviewer] Right, you're improving.
If you look at it on a daily basis
you're having big ups and big downs.
- (indistinct) exactly
what you just said. I mean,
- [interviewer] over the long haul,
- okay, what I'm taking,
I guess my foot is up now
it's not even down yet it's up.
So I'm making a strive forward you know,
because I wouldn't usually
I wouldn't be here.
- [Are you better off today
than you were three months ago?
- I think I'm getting there.
- [interviewer] Yeah,
that's a good attitude.
- I think I'm getting there.
This this little well not little,
this run I've seen a little bit more
than what I usually see.
I see how it's changing
people and you know,
when you when you come from
a sober state going to this.
I don't know about other people for me,
I watch everything and
I'm watching some shit
this is I'm like God damn,
but I'm continuing to smoke.
(indistinct) and I got to do that.
But I'm looking at it,
man It's just it's ugly.
It's rarely really ugly
and bottom line is,
we gotta grasp that were with all again.
But take it slow with or without.
take it slow,
- [interviewer] you're you're demanding
too much of yourself.
- Right? Right. You know,
- [interviewer] it's your
subconscious that needs to change
not your conscious coz your conscious
you're intelligent enough
to know that drugs are bad
and this lifestyle of living
on the street is destructive.
It's not about that it's 100.
(engine roaring)
It's all about what
your subconscious belief
is about yourself, and what you deserve.
And once that really changes,
then all of a sudden,
you'd be like, why the
hell did I ever spend
time down there?
But you can't you're not there yet.
So you can't command that out of yourself,
- And just got to dig deeper
And what is going to happen slowly
I don't think recovery
is a fast process at all.
you know, I mean, it
takes people some time
and for whatever it takes, they
have to work through issues
and things like that.
So I gotta go through some shit.
You know, sometimes I'm gonna
stand maybe I might fall
I don't know but at least
I'm giving an honest effort
to do so.
- [interviewer] Yeah, now
you're doing everything right
in my eyes.
I just think it's not an addiction issue.
It looks like a little thing
you're you're a drug addict.
And that's the problem.
To me it's a self love issue
and you are making incremental
changes in your ability
to love yourself.
Because it's gonna be the
hardest thing you ever change.
As I said earlier, it's
gonna be the hardest thing
we ever change about ourselves.
And it doesn't happen like that.
- Right?
- [interviewer] You know,
even even if you have a wonderful change,
like you, you get a great job back
you're making the money you used to make
and all that kind of stuff.
All these wonder a great
woman in your life,
whatever you want.
All these great things
that happened to you.
You won't make a miraculous
change in your subconscious
belief about yourself overnight.
It's still gonna take
a long time to change.
And that's where people
who have had huge success
will set self sabotage because
they they weren't ready
for that much success.
- Yeah, I asked myself, Donald
asked me last night he said,
man, do you fear success?
First time in my life I ever said yes.
He looked at me he said, Okay.
He said, You remember they
asked us that question
a couple of years ago, when we
were both in the same place?
I said yeah.
He said you were only one
out of the group to say no.
He said, but you do.
It's the fear of the
unknown fear of success.
He said, when you'll find it,
- [interviewer] it's great
that you're aware of that.
Because you're confident
and you're competent.
And you're self assured
and you have all these great qualities,
But that doesn't mean you
still can doubt yourself
and feel like you're
deserving that's common.
- I'm human shit is gonna happen.
- [interviewer] How many
beautiful women are insecure?
All of them Almost all
- I agree I mean man, we're
just gonna keep going.
So I get it better meaning, though,
that woke up at six o'clock this morning.
My buddy was asleep.
And I was just staring at the window.
And something came and
said slowly, but surely.
slowly, but surely.
I'm like, Okay.
I read that as you asked
what too damn fast.
You didn't check the boat
fully before you sailed.
And that's why she podcast
but you're gonna get
a hole in the bow but you didn't drown.
- [interviewer] You didn't drown.
- You had the wherewithal
to swim to the shore.
So now that you're on the shore,
you don't have to lay
down on the sand on it.
- [interviewer] I don't see
you any differently today
than I did during our last two talks,
which were really positive, right?
You're the same person
you're just having a bad day,
bad week, bad month bad whatever.
But I believe in you, and I
think you're doing amazing work.
- Thank you very much.
We gonna do it one day at
a time you know continue.
And you guys will surely see me again.
You can believe that we're gonna do it.
- [interviewer] Excellent
Very good luck this week.
Thank you.
- [interviewer] Alright thanks
- Damn, for some reason, some just what
I think as I'm finally
admitted out for your success.
- [interviewer] Having
these talks are great.
- Granny drove me, my grandma.
She's a businesswoman
she owns five cleaners.
She's president of the mother's board.
She's president of her Eastern star,
which is a women's form of
the What do you call him?
fuck masons.
You know, I came home one day
there's senator John Conyers
on one side of the couch
and Mira Coleman young
on the other one and I'm like,
but they were talking to
her about her testifying
this Robert Chamberlain
Roberts Chamberlain or
Richard Chamberlain
I think its one of those.
He was the guy who planted
the bomb in the Sixth Street
Baptist Church that
killed those four girls.
And my grandmother has seen
him and testify against him
its 1977 he died in 1981.
And I'm sitting here looking,
I never knew I remember
when FBI agents came around.
And I say, grandma, she
said, Who's that at the door?
for white guys with badges (indistinct)
Yeah, So we put them in
They went in, they closed
door linear for some hours.
And I remember they left and I said,
Well, I'm gonna be gone
for a couple of weeks.
I'm like, Well, I'll
tell you when I get back.
I think three days later, my grandpa said,
that's a good picture I said, Who?
He said your grandma. Look.
I said granny testify.
She's the woman who got one
of those guys convicted.
You know, and I was like, Wow, man.
saw her positions.
My family's position.
Yeah, you know, you got your
100 you got to stand up.
You know, I've never been
able to stand up there.
Simply coz I really didn't want to
- [interviewer] Much pressure.
- Yeah, too much I go
to 24th Street school.
And the teachers say
oh, this is Norman fine.
All your sisters Dorothy and
Benita they're straight A's.
One behind each other
valedictorian valedictorian.
So guess what I was valedictorian.
So I'm following in his footsteps.
And it's like his pressure
you got to succeed
You got to succeed got to see
when all and all that says,
I fear that shit like a motherfucker, man.
And I've never admitted what
a book I'm saying right now.
Scared to death.
I went to the interview
at Disney scared to death.
didn't know what was gonna come out.
When a guy told me he says Norman Wow,
what are you doing After an interview?
I says, Well, I'm going home.
So I'm gonna have lunch
why don't you join me?
I knew I had a job there.
And it ease that but
I was scared to death.
I'm going up against some
powerful people you know,
some pretty, pretty
student engineers, you know
And I got the fucking job. You know
I mean, you're in charge of 260 engineers.
I go to Disney World, a
Euro Disney. You know,
I mean all expenses paid.
And we don't live in the life
of Riley and I was sober now
So by the summer, two and a
half years when I got the job
I stayed sober six years,
10 months to two days.
brought it down coz I stopped
doing what I was doing
to get there you know
I Yeah, fear success.
Yeah, I do so we'll see what happens
- [interviewer] we will.
(indistinct)
- Yes sir.
- [interviewer] Thank you.
- Yeah, anytime.